[Music]
spooky oh that's different
are we in a city
[Music]
interest oh okay that's weird cool
no alrighty then hello everybody my name
is markiplier and welcome to the hello
neighbor beta now this is the beta it is
no longer in alpha they say the game is
good enough to be able to put into beta
so that's exactly what we're gonna be
doing here so I've got this I don't know
about the shape of my head but I don't
think these binoculars are gonna fit it
well amazingly they do and I can still
tell you the binoculars so it's out of
alpha which means if it's in a better
playable state right cool
Greg and throw that away hello-o
I can see myself I'm so handsome
alright yes without that telegram I
don't know what the [ __ ] I just saw but
it was not normal human motion I didn't
read it okay well I guess I got invited
somewhere or I'm moving so I guess I get
to get get the Frick out of here hey let
me back up my meager belongings my
absolute nothing did I have nothing I
own nothing I am nothing I'm just a big
nothing well there's my key that's the
key input drawer robbing us key
something real garden you want to get
keyed okay
I didn't work all right whatever oh I'm
in the city
flip-flap okay alright then find the key
put the key in the suitcase Oh got it
nailed it find my mouse with the buy
knocks know about to throw it out the
window I don't think that's it yeah I'm
gonna take a look e for you where are
you at how C Wow see I can't move until
I see it oh boy I hope I see it I sure
want to move out of this hellhole the
city where are you okay that's not
that's obviously not it okay can I open
my oh I'm so hesitant what am I looking
pensively at I was not like there's much
to memory here no reminiscent in this
place just future potential always
looking forward to the future okay well
now we're in the neighborhood oh I'm
driving hello neighbor I see your place
is less crazy than it was more boarded
up than it has been in the past also why
am i pulling into his driveway wait is
this my house swamp
where this my house wait a minute wait a
hanky honky second here wait a Hank
Horkan second wait a moment
hang on a second aah
I'm seeing something here kurchuk you
just pull it off you're so strong I know
you can do it no never mind do we do win
be very wimpy baby all right what do I
got here I got something in the boot of
my car I do have it something in the
boot of my car all right
oh wow
oh good something staring at me from my
closet that's nice all right I'm gonna
go over here hang on a second I need to
see what's in this house if anything's
still here excuse no it's weird dr.
Seuss style neighborhood no nothing all
right okay then I trust this got a great
deal on this bad boy ah yeah oh good
stuff oh you can smell the rich history
in this place here oh no I can't open
now in that weird doorman don't open mmm
mysteriously all the doors in my new
place are locked
Oh free furniture-grade I just save so
much money at IKEA all right let's get
my stuff in whatever my stuff is is this
my only stuff one box of stuff here all
I need moving in
well moved in now that felt good this
one share also I have chair anybody know
that I have chair is my stuff anybody
did more stuff no I don't think so
ooh another box I'm rich I've got a
bounty of stuff wait can I now move this
one this is firmly stuck to my car I
guess they're gonna pocket I have one
bucket anybody want to know what my
bucket is
ok never mind then ok
[Music]
oh no that's that's not good that's not
good
I don't like that
I can do that too
[Music]
what what wait a minute huh running oh
hi okay ah a reason that sound oh okay
what this happened huh whatever my
cookies this is so broken how is this
you this doesn't make any sense this is
so broken this game is broken this game
is like broke and broken I mean oh yeah
you're not supposed to go in this out
I'm supposed to get here you're not
supposed to go in you're just you're not
supposed to go in the amazing door that
has nothing in it
wow that door is off its hinges it's the
door didn't reset right oh this this
don't even move right well hi hello
welcome to the neighborhood I'm just
gonna leave you know I don't even
understand anything that's happening
here this makes no sense yep can't do
that I'm good what's happening I don't
understand you I want to go now
I can't leave can't leave
can't leave you can't move can't leave
so I won't leave I won't move can't pick
that up if I move I die if I move I die
well this is fun okay no I can't go that
way
all right let me try this again so all
right i reinstated again shall we throw
nice open oh what what oh that door is
not normal what is happening it I don't
understand I don't understand me
press eat oh wow
wowie wow wow wow oh wow oh gee schoo oh
gee Scoob oh gee Scoob oh gee Scoob
I'm trying to hide oh there we go okay I
hid
all righty then hmm hi okay everything
is fine it's a beta okay all right now
that we're out of that weird world I
don't know what the hell was happening
there I have no idea I haven't got the
foggiest clue and why is this exactly
like my apartment in the city it's the
exact same they just transplanted it
here what is this what is this I'm so
confused
[Applause]
it seems like the quality has degraded I
can't believe this I want you know okay
all right I'm goofing around a bit but
also why did this regress why did this
game go backwards in terms of
development why did this game go
backwards in terms of like any sort of
finesse - you know what I mean it just
seems like it's a little lackluster here
all right whatever
anyway I'm gonna try to explore and see
whatever's new but it looks like there's
a lot of pieces that are still the same
as what they won't swerve I'll poo where
all the dead bodies he wears that crow
grow grow grow grow grow bird Raven
sorry took me a while to get there but
Raven how are you doing you okay you
guarding this box it's a nice box you
mind me sitting in your box mr. crow
Raven sorry blackbird hello you there
bird you want a red key you wanna be
jump pizza box you want trashcan lid
nope bird hello bird come on Ferb apple
corer erb erb gotta eat Ferb gotta eat
baby rube got eat
know all about to throw my key in anger
well ki disappeared into the ground not
JooJoo feed the burbs here
Oh your nose shrank over time buddy food
I don't know how that happened all right
anyway just gotta build your bird I
don't know what this word means but per
turn the bull weapon is that your name
mister weapon mr. preacher noble you
want Chinese food you want Chinese
takeout Barbra it's free food right
there you get your noodles how about
empty milk carton calcium good for your
bones
No maybe I gotta get in your box good
you're doing good bird you get you get
box in box all right
good day to you burb have a nice take
care
much love love love well anyway let's
see if I can do the old razzle-dazzle on
them what people never see me you will
never hear that ever apparently what how
did you see how how can you slap well
don't even time going in your house
doodly-doo gonna lock you out
doodlee do you've been locked down mo
the rubber need a lot of expedia Dix its
are good for you fooled approach nope
that was wrong missing my target hurry
up T
yup T okay good I got the into your glue
collection well this all seems similar
and it's a new here nope huh Biscay good
thing I don't have that red key anymore
I probably could have used it would have
been too unfair advantage for me oh I'm
Brewer maybe Birbal like this well that
went places just like I'm going I got
enough barely curve I'm so grumpy got my
grub levels or all the shirt you get it
Ellard you get burnt all sorry I didn't
mean to do that to your window hey come
here come here let me have a
conversation with you man-to-man
hey buddy buddy booth going in your
house
loser right goosh goosh take tois spoo
sh t douche right so there we got this
whole deal can't be much about it boink
D oh well alright well you keep an eye
on that I'm gonna go try do so mails so
I need something small enough to be able
to throw through the little gap in the
back to be able to get to the lover
alright paternal you ain't gonna mind if
I take this to eat returnable Oh
peculiar over there huh Skoosh who would
what and how and who did that you son of
a [ __ ] ten thousand [ __ ] all right
glasses
Elmo be stealthy you ain't gonna see
[ __ ] because I'm crouching all of a
sudden oh somehow you heard that how do
you off you got close okay he's grumpy
now he's real grumpy well I hit that
patch of glue I heard a squeak oh well
good it's nice over there al mentum
meant to not do that but did it anyway
hello Chinese day going up I'm going up
I don't know where I'm going but I'm
going up nice where am I now
ooh where is this hello nothing
I didn't bring a flashlight not a
flashlight I didn't bring a flashlight
well [ __ ] let me see if I can squiggle
out of this one I've got some pretty
good squiggling skills nope ain't no
schooling and gonna get me out of this
one
you're a big I'm good I saw apple core
hey buddy hey buddy how you mind if I go
right in your front door oh yeah sure
you do
oh yeah here I go he didn't even notice
what do you do ah why he why game I oh
I'm in the wall again really Wow game oh
man I wanna like yeah I wanna like a
game but you got damn it okay
all right there's the gap don't want to
go shop at the gap
da da made it out of the gap that was
that was a close call what's this piece
of wood nothing all right why are we
here Oh what did that do I'm not a
hundred percent sure
okay made it here why off this did me no
good did it oh good great I wasn't
supposed to come here I'm gonna slide
right off the roof if I try to go that
way so I'm gonna go the only way that
seems logical which is to go over there
not logical but you know ooh what about
that I see you right there can I land on
you I think I can do Skoosh Hey hey
buddy hey buddy are you doing keeping an
eye watchful eye that's good that's good
it's good
what's this is it so why is there a
train excuse you good to know this big
red button did absolutely dick Oh
oh it did not do dick it did more than
dick it did woo ah me sacrifices apple
core huh well that's happening now not
sure what to do about that made it
safely here oh it's smashed open the do
burrs it smashed the do burrs okay so if
it smashed the do burrs then I'm going
to do
[Music]
all right I got a peel I got an inner
peel here's the hole
I want to go in the hole hole in I
should have turned it off shouldn't I
have should I have not have done that
well testing fate with walking on this
oh there it is that's far away from me
that's gonna be fine all right cool why
does he have this why does he have this
at all why is this a thing that he has
where is it where is it oh there it is
oh hi oh yes please okay [ __ ] you then -
great all right let me try this leads
this way where does this lead oh oh here
is rock man didn't want to go in here
rock me like a hurricane interesante oh
I can control you it now sorry still got
mine an appeal never gonna let go mine
an appeal
oh nice drop into nothingness I don't
think I want to go there just yet so
this is the control room that I just was
were at turn that son of a [ __ ] off
stop
good okay you stay there for a little
bit you rest your weary head oh oh
well that did nothing okay great glad I
did that okay let me follow the tracks
for a little bit longer
chugalug chugalug look at me chugalug oh
right so this is just back to where I
was what is that
excuse you what excuse you what what is
that what is oh why he's never gonna be
able to get me here he's able to get me
here I'm a monkey's blood hole I know
there's gonna work cuz I've
definitely done this before and it's
worked before every time I wanted to do
this every time it's worked flawlessly
yep that's part of the flawless plan all
right here we go
flawless flawless flawless ah William
Wallace flawless okay not quite there I
was right there get out of my face yeah
oh yeah
made it made it what did I win frying
pan that's what I won
why's frying pan on the wall don't ask
too many clowns we're for frying pan oh
that's weird then why are you all green
key you're up here for some reason I
can't even grab you you're not you don't
exist
I forgot this beta ah yes beta ah yes
beta well that didn't work I brought you
all this way mean or peel didn't work
don't know why I thought it would have
worked but it didn't work
oh you know what I think that's enough
mayhem for one episode I'm gonna end
this one here I criticized it a lot just
because like there's a lot more stuff
but I can't honestly say that the stuff
is better and that's the one thing that
I'll say about it because if I'm
expecting as the game develops it's
gonna get like more logical and sensible
and you know it just seems even more
nonsensical than it was before so
there's a lot more but it's less refined
you know what I mean what is happening
in there what the what is happening in
there I don't know what's happening but
I'm gonna try it again that window nope
Wow okay well this I expected to slide
off this and I didn't
all righty then how much farther can I
go on the oh not farther I'm dead now
apparently okay but either way that is
all the time I got for hello neighbor
thank you everybody so much for watching
this probably new secrets in this
version of hello neighbor but my god is
it uglier so thank you everybody so much
for watching let me know what you
thought down in the comments below is it
better is it worse no and thanks again
for watching and as always I will see
you in the next video
[Music]